good morning believe nation today's
message is turn pain into greatness over
to you Machine Gun Kelly people used to
take my raps and crunch them up and
throw them on the ground I used to get
made fun of all the time because who
believes that the guy sitting next in a
math class is gonna blow up and become a
superstar
you don't write that right but like you
should and it's a bummer you know I mean
because I yeah I don't know man I mean
take it take it and make you know pain
is the best inspiration so if you're a
creative out there and you're getting
bullied take it and make something great
up so what do you think I think that's a
really important message when I first
started dancing I was told that I would
be a decent dancer
I best at best I wasn't very good and my
feet are actually not equipped to dance
because I have really flat feet and I
used to get a lot of pain in my feet and
it would always shake especially during
performances and I told myself that I'm
gonna make myself strong so I did really
really painful ballet exercises and
eventually I became stronger and now I'm
able to go on stage and perform and also
change the physiology of my foot I wish
I could show you but I can't right now
but I never had an arch but I have been
watching it
Wow yes and that's a knee I mean to most
people is not a big deal where to me is
a huge deal good I was told I could be a
dancer because of my feet cool when I
was at my agency when I first connected
to them they told me that I wasn't good
enough to join the agency they liked my
message but I couldn't speak which hurt
because I'd already done two years of
public speaking and I felt like I should
be a little better than I can't speak
and most of the people at their agency
they said could speak but they didn't
have a message and so they we're willing
to take a risk on me and so I worked
really hard I wanted to take that pain
that rejection and turn into something
amazing
and so I practice every single day
working on my creation story and
sometimes three times a day making
videos back and forth and back and forth
and I started getting better in a couple
months I became the best practice at the
agency and people were saying you should
go look what Evans doing not because I
was great I had the least talent of
anybody there I just worked hard so I
was making three videos a day we're
mostly for having a hard time coming
we come with excuses to say I don't have
time to make one video a week more than
that is just too much and so that's why
I got better and so if you have a goal
if somebody is telling you that you
can't do it it's just work put in the
work get better at it practice practice
practice you can become a better speaker
you can change the physiology of your
foot they have a great dancer whatever
your goal is you can chase it put in the
work so the question of the day today is
what is the pain that you're struggling
with right now to overcome I love it
leave it in the comments we'll join in
the discussion finally you want to give
a quick shout out to Ron Ron thank you
so much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word it really really really
means a lot to me and I hope then joined
the week so thank you guys so much for
watching we believe in you we hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
and we'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso when one
does have to be focused on the short
term and money coming in when creating
company because otherwise the company
will die so that I think that a lot of
times people think like creating company
is gonna be fun I would say it's not
it's really not that fun when there are
periods of fun and there are periods of
where it's just awful and particularly
if you CEO of the company you actually
have a distillation of all the worst
problems in a company there's no point
in spending your time on things that are
going right so you only spend on things
on your time and things that are going
wrong and and there are things that are
going wrong that other people can't
can't take care of so you're like the
worst you have a filter for the
crappiest problems in the company the
most pernicious and painful problem so I
wouldn't say it's it's I think you have
to feel quite compelled to do it and
have a fairly high pain threshold and
there's a friend of mine who says like
starting companies like staring into the
abyss and eating glass and there's some
truth to that
we're starting to the best part is that
you're going to be constantly facing the
extermination of the company because
most most startups fail it's like 90
percent
luckily 99% of Starks fail so I so you
that bets the staring into the abyss
part you can't so constantly saying okay
let's if I don't get this right the
company will die should be quite
rightful quite stressful and and then
the eating class part is you've got
you've got to do you've got to do the
problems you're gonna sell you're gonna
work on the problems that the company
needs you to work on that promise you
want to work on and so that the that's
you and I've working on problems that
that you really wish you weren't working
on okay so that's the eating glass part
then that goes on for a long time